a rock that students call a symbol of
racism has been removed from university
of wisconsin fifty
thousand dollars to remove a 42-ton
boulder it's a rock
[Music]
demand for racism outstrips supply at
this point okay we now have a couple
more stories along these lines so over
the last 24 hours the colorado rockies
decided that it was necessary to
investigate a man who supposedly was
shouting the n-word and miami marlins
outfielder louis brinson during his
at-bat
according to the new york post quote
this is the original story rocky's
investigating after fan hurls racial
slur at marlin's player okay from that
headline you would determine that the
fan was hurling a racial slur at the
marlins player after all that is the
entire headline and in fact
people were tweeting this thing out
including blue check marks
the colorado rockies put out a statement
saying the colorado rockies are
disgusted at the racial slur by a fan
directed at the marlins lewis brinson
during the ninth inning of today's game
although the subject was not identified
prior to the end of the game the rockies
are still investigating this incident
the rockies have zero tolerance for any
form of racism or discrimination and any
fan using derogatory language of any
kind will be ejected and barred from
coors field
okay and uh and then a statement was put
out by the major league baseball players
association executive director and
former yankee tony clark he said it is a
painful reality that progress continues
to be elusive in a world where ignorance
and bigotry remain all too commonplace
okay so again this is always the idea is
that one instance of racism means that
everybody is racist and racism still
runs right throughout american life that
in and of itself is really stupid an
isolated incident is isolated and
noteworthy because it is isolated and
also noteworthy
okay an isolated incident if it is
indicative of broad national trends
generally is not isolated and you can
name many instances of this sort of
stuff happening but this was a national
story literally one person supposedly
shouting the n-word at a baseball player
you had the major league baseball
players association commenting on this
you had major league baseball itself
commenting on this had the colorado
rockies commenting on all this okay then
the rockies started to do an
investigation
and what they found is that the man was
not in fact shouting the n-word in fact
here is the video of the man not
shouting the n-word he is not shouting
the n-word here he is shouting at the
kalo rock he's the colorado rockies
mascot whose name is dinger okay he's
shouting at the mascot
here's what the tape sounded like
three yesterday here's the 1-0
[Music]
and again it's 2-0 and this is not to
pick on
okay he's not shouting the n-word he's
shouting dinger
dinger that's the name of the team's
mascot
a denver news reporter this is the this
is the new york post the next day right
walking it back a denver news reporter
who spoke to the rockies organization
said the team interviewed the fan about
the incident the rockies tell me last
night's incident was a fan shouting to
get the attention of the rocky's mascot
dinger not a racial slur the rockies
have spoken to the fan who confirms this
is the case they've also reviewed the
video from the local broadcast
so
a lot of people again in the blue
checkmark world had decided this was
indicative of major league baseball fans
more generally or america more generally
but as it turns out that wasn't the
story at all and now the colorado
rockies had to put out an update on this
in which they admitted that the fan was
indeed yelling for rocky's mascot dinner
in hopes of getting his attention for a
photo and there was never any racial
slur that occurred
the rockies remain dedicated to
providing an inclusive environment for
all fans players and guests at coors
field and any fan using derogatory
language of any kind will be ejected
from coors field okay well thank you for
that meaningless notification
considering that nobody said anything
racist
okay this was a massive national story
it was a major national story
that people were a guy was supposedly
yelling the n-word at a black baseball
player when he was in fact not and that
was not the only story that is like this
cnn reports today quote a rock that
students call a symbol of racism has
been removed from university of
wisconsin okay now you may notice that
there's a little bit of hedging in that
particular title right a rock that
students call a symbol of racism so is
the rock a symbol of racism or is the
rock not a symbol of racism well as it
turns out the rock is absolutely not a
symbol of racism in fact there is pretty
much no evidence that the rock was ever
a symbol of racism
according to cnn itself the university
of wisconsin removed a 42-ton boulder
from its madison campus on friday after
complaints from students of color who
called the rock a symbol of racism
chamberlain rock which had sat on
observatory points since 1925 was named
after thomas chamberlain a geologist and
former university president who served
from 1887 to 1892.
so um what's racist about that was
thomas chamberlin a vicious slave
holding racist or something
nope there was one article from the
wisconsin state journal in 1925 that
used the n-word as part of a nickname
for the giant boulder
that's the whole thing
an article they used the n-word and a
nickname for the rock
and now they spent i kid you not 50
to remove a 42-ton boulder for no reason
other than apparently students of color
at the university of wisconsin are
offended by a rock
that is not racist because it's a rock
that is not racist
the wisconsin black student union last
summer called for the rock to be removed
from campus as one of a series of
demands it said were aimed at seeking
justice for black students the campaign
came in the wake of the police killings
of george floyd and brianna taylor
senior nala mcquarter said in a
university news release quote it was
very meaningful for me to be there and
to see the process all the way through
to the end
mcquarter who was the president of the
wisconsin black student union for the
past academic year was there when the
boulder was removed on friday quote it
was about a year ago that we released
our demands and met with the chancellor
and explained to her why those demands
meant so much to us it was a powerful
moment today to see this demand come
full circle
amazing
amazing by the way the rock also had to
be removed because a native american
student organization named wonk
chic partnered with the wisconsin black
student union in the rock removal effort
because the boulder sat on ancestral
ho-chunk land
the university actually had to get
permission from the wisconsin historical
society to remove the boulder because
it's sat within the area of a native
american burial mound according to the
university
so they moved the rock because nothing
because literally nothing like there's
no evidence that the rock is racist
nobody sees the rock as racist it's a
rock it's a rock
like literally the the most they can say
is that an article from about a hundred
years ago used the n-word while
referring to the rock
the chancellor's office is using private
donations to pay the 50 000 price tag
for the rock's removal the university
said it's now being moved to university
on land near lake kagansa southeast of
madison first of all i don't think
that's appropriate i think this rock has
to go directly in the lake right i mean
it's a racist rock just removing it to
another piece of land doesn't that make
that piece of land racist i've been
reliably informed that according to as
james lindsey says critical rock theory
this rock is a is a foundation stone for
systemic racism so just moving it to
another piece of land somewhere isn't
going to do it it must be buried deep
under actually we can't even bury it
deep underground we need to shoot it
into the sun
that is the only way to cleanse this
planet of racism
this rock some idiot in 1925 use the
n-word to refer to the rock the only way
to solve this problem is to
build the world's largest trebuchet and
fire the rock into orbit hopefully out
of orbit hopefully it doesn't even stay
like orbiting the planet it needs to go
we need to chisel this thing down to
sand that's the other possibility
we all every white person in america
owes a duty to go with a chisel and a
hammer and chisel this giant rock down
to sand
only then will racism be alleviated in
the united states if you're getting the
feeling that um people are lazy and
stupid in the united states and that
they spend a lot of time worrying about
things that really ought not be worried
about that would be correct
that our media are too lazy and stupid
to actually investigate the true stories
of these things and if they do they are
too pusillanimous to actually stand up
and say wait a second you're telling me
that somebody's supposed to spend 50
grand to move a giant ass rock because
somebody called it a racist term a
hundred years ago are you out of your
mind
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content